mr. speaker one of the most important
sectors for job creation is housing the
construction sector adds 39 billion
pounds a year to the UK economy house
building alone supports nearly 3/4 of a
million jobs with millions more relying
on the availability of housing to find
work but property transactions fell by
50 percent in May house prices have
fallen for the first time in eight years
an uncertainty abounds in the market a
market we need to be thriving
we need people feeling confident
confident to buy sell renovate move and
improve that will drive growth that will
create jobs so to catalyze the housing
market and boost confidence I have
decided today to cut stamp duty right
now there is no stamp duty on
transactions below a hundred and twenty
five thousand pounds today I am
increasing the threshold to half a
million pounds this will be a temporary
cut running until the 31st of March next
year and as is always the case these
changes to stamp duty will take effect
immediately
the average Stamp Duty bill will fall by
four and a half thousand pounds and
nearly nine out of ten people buying a
main home this year will pay no stamp
duty at all